you know what movies are usually good in
a truly safe kind of way international
spy movies I'm just saying domestic spy
movies usually suck international spy
movies pretty safe bet just saying if
you want to write a movie or direct a
movie international spy movie
[Music]
jack ryan shadow recruit so jack ryan
shadow recruit stars Chris Pine as the
character Jack Ryan
Jack Ryan's a Tom Clancy character who's
the main character in movies like
Patriot Games clear and present danger
The Hunt for Red October and sum of all
fears now he's the main character and
jack ryan shadow recruit you know that
because it's called jack ryan shadow
recruit jack ryan shadow recruit Slyke
the genesis of how he got into the CIA
how it became an analyst and how he
became a field agent who's still an
analyst which is one of the things I
don't buy about the movie you first see
him I believe it's in college or high
school one of the two point is it's in
2001 and there is young Jack Ryan and it
picks up a couple years later and you're
like alright still young Jack rise it's
gonna take place back then note then it
picks up ten years later so you're like
okay this whole span that I just saw is
about 13 years and he looks the same I
just say 13 years someone's gonna change
but not Chris Pine Jim Kirk never
changes well that's not true but now
Jack Ryan has to go after the director
of this movie Kenneth Branagh is really
bad Russian guy who's gonna crumble
America that's right the Cold War may be
over but we're America we keep the fear
alive that is how you pronounce his name
right Kenneth Brenner I heard him say
it's pronounced Kenneth Brenner like
Bruce Banner branner
but everyone still pronounces his name
Branagh because that's how it's spelled
but until he comes to me he's like
Jeremy is pronounced Branagh I'm still
gonna say Brenner I got your back can it
ran off and how is this movie it's an
international spy movie and I mean that
in a good way granted there are some
shitty international spy movies this
really isn't one of them this movies
like if James Bond and Mission
Impossible went splat which is really
funny because James Bond is pretty much
British Mission Impossible is it as good
as Mission Impossible Ghost Protocol or
Skyfall no it's not I'm just saying it's
a good spy movie it's a fun movie they
have their spy scenarios that they have
to do and they have to do spy things
lemma is that means the movie really
played it safe because everything in
this movie I'm like I've seen that
before big chase at the end I've seen
that before uh sit down dinner with the
bad guys seeing that before a lot of
stuff in this movie I'm like I have seen
it all before Batman said I don't mind
seeing it again because it's still good
I ain't surprised how no one in the
movie annoyed me Chris Pine I like Chris
Pine is he Jack Ryan I don't know
read the books that's for this movie I
thought he was actually pretty good
Keira Knightley plays his girlfriend in
the movie who doesn't know what he does
he has to keep it a secret yes you have
seen that before but the point is she's
a girlfriend in a spy movie I'm like
that is like having a kid in the movie
dad on Orion well actually no she's
she's pretty good she did not annoy me
Kevin Costner's in the movie he was cool
I will say there's a scene I love it's
the first time Jack Ryan kills somebody
I love that scene a lot of times in spy
movies they kill somebody and you forget
that it's the first time they would have
killed somebody I mean they killed the
person the person is dead they blinked
their life out of existence and then
they go about their day this movie
wasn't like that you really see Jack
Ryan dealing with it for the aftermath
he's just he's really sketchy shaking
you knows like that's how it should be
thank you for bringing that to life good
job jack ryan shadow recruit indian jack
ryan shadow recruit it was a spy movie
like you've seen before Russians are
doing bad Russian things Jack Ryan has
to stop him it's fun stuff to watch but
it's not breaking new ground or anything
however Chris Pine did a good job and
the supporting cast didn't annoy me I
thought Kenneth Branagh was a good bad
guy he's a good bad guy in that he's a
Russian businessman I wouldn't mess with
someone like that ever it looks like
this you know he barely opens his mouth
check I know both rip your spine out
then look at like I'm a madman like this
I wouldn't mess with someone ever what
does this mean friends it simply means
jack ryan shadow recruit is a really
good time no alcohol required
alright so jack ryan shadow recruit have
you seen it what did you think about it
what do you think of Chris Pine as young
Jack Ryan good to know - whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you liked what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]